I just want I just wanted to do it our
way
you know on our own man I should have
gotten some food maybe some spaghetti
okay Kevin you can take off that thing
okay
sound really really showing him up
witness I brought in some burritos or
some colored greens or some pad thai
love pad thai its collard greens what
it's collard greens Klan doesn't really
make sense cuz you don't call them
Collard people that's offensive mmm okay
well that's after 5:00 so thank you very
much
Buena Vista Oscar thank you good job I'm
a man Thank You Brazil nice
we can go
not a bad day
Jim's bedroom
see I knew we lost some money on the
tour cool this is your desk this is my
desk
your Home Office Home Office this is it
yeah you have to sit down so I can get
the full effect
okay sure will do okay wait so that
would make me like right here yeah yep
that feels about it huh and then Dwight
would be like um you know what let's
just leave that image out of it because
this is a happy place happy thoughts
your book yeah you don't have to all
right yes that's not gonna be awkward at
all oh yeah
you're so dorky thank you
you know you don't have to answer calls
during a party just thought you should
know no I was just checking out my
present but I traded with Dwight um just
I figured you know you went to a lot of
trouble and that means a lot and also
Roy got me an iPod or was going to get
me an iPod so well either way this is an
amazing gift because it comes with bonus
gifts yeah I think I made the right
choice incredible is this the boggle
timer I didn't think you really let that
one I really do
you have seven unheard messages hey Jim
Pam I keep looking up to say something
to you and then Michaels there and it's
horrible anyway Lord come back hey guess
what
I moved my computer so I can't see
Michaels head it's working I think I can
have a career as a very specific type of
decorator sudo COO double moderate time
18 minutes
suck on that Halpert I'll transfer you
Dunder Mifflin this is Pam please Dunder
Mifflin this is okay sorry Michael was
standing at my desk and I need to be
busier who knows what would have
happened so thank you hey what's that
word we made up for when you have a
thing stuck in your shoe anyway I have a
thing stuck in my shoe hey I have a
chance to sneak out of here early and
I'm not messing this up so I'll see you
tomorrow
calling from my cellphone I don't know
if you guys figured out who did that to
Michael's carpet yet but I have a theory
that involves an interdepartmental
conspiracy everybody in the office We
Need to Talk I had plans to meet a
friend tonight which I had to cancel but
this is cool too I'm not a complainer
Wow for the bugs
nice that's excellent because bugs love
my famous grilled cheese sandwich
ladies I can't remember the last time
someone made me dinner
[Music]
so I guess I'll see you in 10 hours what
are you gonna do with your time off
travel yeah I'm gonna get bored it's
gonna be really nice
I'm gonna find myself you have any music
yeah definitely
[Applause]
about 10 minutes ago how I didn't know
what to say yes I know um I don't know
mom he's my best friend yeah he's great
yeah I think I am um I have to go I will
listen Jim
oh I mean truly repulsive that is a very
very funny story hey I want to say
something I've been trying to be more
honest lately and I just need to say a
few things I did the cold walk just I
did it
Michael you couldn't even do that maybe
I should be your boss
Wow I feel really good right now why
didn't any of you come to my art show I
invited all of you that really sucked
it's like sometimes some of you act like
I don't even exist Jim I called off my
wedding because of you and now we're not
even friends and things are just like
weird between us and that sucks and I
miss you you were my best friend before
you went to Stanford I really miss you I
shouldn't have been with Roy
there are a lot of reasons to call off
my wedding but the truth is I didn't
care about any of those reasons until I
met you and now you're with someone else
and that's fine it's whatever that's not
what I'm I'm not okay my feet really
hurt the thing that I'm just trying to
say to you Jim and to everyone else in
the circle I guess is that I miss having
fun with you just you not everyone in
the circle
okay I am gonna go walk in the water now
yeah it's a good day
Pam that was amazing
but I am still looking for someone with
a sales background this is Pam I just
one moment I'll transfer you I haven't
heard anything but I'd bet Jim got the
job I mean why wouldn't he he's totally
qualified and smart everyone loves him
and if he never comes back again that's
okay we're friends and I'm sure we'll
stay friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know I shot him down and then he did
this name to me and but you know what
it's okay I'm totally fine everything is
gonna be totally sorry um are you free
for dinner tonight
yes all right then it's a date
questions
you